welcome to testing time incorporated
your new career as a junior death
prevention agent begins today oh but
first you must learn the basics required
for permanent outline well the hyper
glove is our most recent info and is
required for satisfactory job
performance okay I guess
ouch forward and put on both gloves now
I don't know if I want to UM hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to just in time in court okay
Wow oh that's not right that right my
hands do not worry about losing your
hyper gloves they are permanently
attached to you and removal would result
in termination Oh your gloves allow you
to manipulate objects in the world
ah okay my hands could do the same thing
you know by touching things
while on a mission your hyper gloves
slow down time so that you may operate
at ten times the speed of a normal
boring human okay but there why the
olives also allow you to teleport now
use your gloves to move forward into the
teleporter yes and hold up on the
touchpad aim at the ground and release
the touchpad to move is that guy's
office just in this elevator should
anybody be worried about that because
that's a little bizarre alright here we
go
we excellent thank you now it is time
for on-the-job training hello hi Julie a
loss prevention specialist it is your
job to make sure our clients are
satisfied ins not dead in front of you
is a hyper clipboard like a regular
clipboard it contains information about
your mission unlike a regular clipboard
it is very expensive
now click the menu button on your
controller huh oh but you may press the
menu button at any time to summon or
dismiss your hyper clipboard
grab your hyper clipboard and click the
play button
but how I'm not even sure I know what
I'm doing here all right whatever it's
probably fine
Jimmy exotic nightclub mugging AIDS 27
frequents dental men's club threat do
whatever you have to to stop the mugging
status unresolved just in time
incorporated PRV number one whoa okay am
I gonna save someone's life that seems
important oh hello chick is in danger
grab your clipboard hit play and save
him from certain death but I thought I
already did this stop don't do that
listen just take his stuff don't kill
him you three think your life choices
don't don't don't don't
okay Oh
[Music]
oh all right that didn't go as planned
excuse me I want to see what's in this
club this seems to be some girls or
something or other stop don't do it oh
oh
um uh-huh I just killed a man I just uh
Oh God um all right all done here
okay I guess we're done then
hi you've saved your first client from
being stabbed okay unfortunately some of
our clients are at risk have been shot
luckily your hyper gloves are able to
grab bullets and redirect them that
doesn't make any sense how is that even
possible
Oh grab the bullet in front of you aim
it at the targets like you would have
gun and release the trigger to fire the
bullet excellent in the real world
bullets move quickly and can kill you
these two targets without dying knot it
and swim oh this is cool oh this is cool
oh I like of this off your training is
now complete and you are ready to save
our next client Oh Ron Klump
high-profile politician threat save our
client by using the assassin's bullets
against him okay I'll do G where am I I
only wise decision our clients as maid
is purchasing one of our policies save
him from being shot
where's the assassin well there is hey
hey mister how about you don't do that
oh [ __ ] ah
I [ __ ] up I'm sorry I I got that all
wrong hang on let me try that again
all right no you won't get him no no
where are you aiming where where where
where are you aiming
I don't appreciate you aiming for my
dick but I like the UH the extra length
that gave me to the tip thank you
feels polite all right whoa oh this is a
problem got it ah [ __ ]
Oh scary this time I'm gonna get it
don't worry I'm gonna get it done
all right hey buddy you are guy about to
get a face full of justice or something
I don't know come to poppy oh oh poor
guy Wow nice okay I guess I did it I
think we're even Am I oh [ __ ] well you
are not dreaming you are standing in
your own personal office when some of
our senior agents have yet to earn this
privilege so please do not brag it is
unbecoming now back to work follow me
okay oh the clipboards here are all open
cases ah grab one and hit play to start
the assignment okay all right but I
think Kevin hi how are you doing alright
see ya
I feel like I'm just getting into this
world and I feel like I've been thrown
into it pretty pretty intensely and I
actually don't understand anything how
this is happening or or why or what kind
of temporal [ __ ] that we have here I
mean are there any other effects that
this is doing to the space-time
continuum I feel like maybe we should be
concerned about the the long-term reaper
can Kevin Kevin Kevin Kevin Kevin Kevin
Kevin Kevin goddamnit
all right fine Kevin you go [ __ ]
yourself I guess I'll just do the rat
outbreak that doesn't even make any
sense
doctor PETA known for new species
development the doctors rodents of
unusual size are escaping all right
whatever you know what you're fine
alright we'll do this one then I guess
hello containment units are
malfunctioning
protect dr. Peter from his unusually
large rodents um okay
no I did I do it
oh that's that's problem that's from hey
you rat bastards Oh God Oh take that Oh
all right that didn't do much take some
of this all right that didn't do much
either how about a face full of this
okay aah aah oh my god oh my god it made
him bigger it made him bigger uh I got a
box cutter
on my stab you almost stabbed you [ __ ]
oh yeah oh [ __ ]
um okay hey yah hey yah yah yah I got
how about some of that yeah ooh oh so
they are dying oh yeah take some of that
uh oh that's a lot more than I thought
that would be my god
I don't know what that did it did
nothing apparently hey yah yah yah yah
yah yah yah yah yah yah oh oh look out
look out look out seem to be that big of
a deal
not exactly a prop oh now he's dying
oh here's oh that guy is very dead okay
all right let's try this again okay you
got it buddy boo ah I think I know how
to do it this time okay this throw those
down there throw those down there nope
you throw those down there oh yeah yeah
we're gonna cut these guys off at the
pass you guys are gonna get it oh yeah
oh yeah well that doesn't seem right
there we go hi-yah oh that got almost
all of them holy [ __ ] um okay
green green yes okay who raised there
more huh oh no poor baby
oh [ __ ] he ran in and he ran it he ran
into that I didn't I didn't put him I
didn't I didn't do that I got it I got
those rats okay all right Kevin Kevin
Kevin or what do we got here
building fire there's a fire building is
caught fire in our clans - trapped in -
Kevin hi what can I do for okay bye
Kevin
so what am I supposed to do about a fire
oh no time it looks like our clients
will have to jump help soften the fall
what couldn't I just go back in time a
little further and stop the fire from
happening in the first place
isn't that an option why didn't we think
of that why why wouldn't we do that why
would we not do that all right I don't
know what these do
Boosh Oh buckle oh oh oh oh oh oh God oh
wait no no no go
okay all right I didn't have time I
didn't know that that's how that was
gonna work so I apologize for that don't
worry I've got you you're gonna be fine
land your taint on my mouth oh did he
make it did did he make it oh yeah oh no
oh God
here we go here we go here we go point
nailed it
anybody else I don't like how they
bounce like that that doesn't seem
incredibly healthy what are you doing
you're not you're not doing anything
can you help okay I think I'm gone oh
yay I did it okay all right good great
Kevin did you see that I did it awooga
bridge escort Marines combat junior plus
I don't even know what does that mean
why is there a gun bang Kevin why is
there a gun Kevin what Kevin why is
there a gun sorry three Maureen's our
boys and blue need help get the three
Marines across the bridge expect heavy
resistance okay
sure fine why not that's probably that's
probably my job Oh
protect the soldiers in blue uniforms
they intend across this very dangerous
bridge why Oh without your help what why
but what did they buy policies am I just
gonna save everybody in the world it
seems like if I do that that nobody's
gonna die what if the guy I had shoot a
bullet towards has a policy to I guess
not apparently oh here we go
what are we gonna do I whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa wait buddy wait be careful
yeah come on come on come here come here
Oh see I kind of feel bad about that I
feel a little little bad about that oh I
feel bad about that one that's going
right for his gullet can I have this
sorry
shot feels bad uh a lot of this just
doesn't seem fair oh god yeah baby
oh sorry yeah sorry sorry can I have
your grenade scoop that right out for
you yeah oh yeah and shahboz game hey I
can actually throw something wait blue
man wait whoa oh that was good aim I
should have used the grenade for
something else um sir oh oh oh got you
baby oh [ __ ] oh Jesus Oh Oh No return to
sender ye oh that guy oh oh oh I'm sorry
oh I did it I won the war aren't you
proud of me I guess okay all right
this game's cool I gotta admit this game
is super super like super love it first
group of clients from gruesome death
yeah we've decided that you can be
trusted with access to some of our more
challenging assignment oh you shouldn't
do that you shouldn't man no no you
probably shouldn't do that that sounds
like a bad thing you definitely
shouldn't do that I'm I'm not
trustworthy at all I don't deserve any
sort of trust trust in the last given a
personal access code to this part of the
building
yours is oh seven oh nine ah Kevin you
better not been listening to that Oh
7:09 work
poor congratulations on your promotion
to associate death prevention ooh ha ha
ha ha ha continue to keep the interests
of our clients your top priority okay
Diane did you hear that Diane I've been
upgraded Diane get your ass back here
Diane Diane Oh
[Music]
oh [ __ ] Diane Diane i Kevin there Kevin
Kevin Oh
oh I'm gonna guess that's perfectly
normal body search someone in the park
is hiding a bomb find it but protect our
clients okay I how do I know who has the
bomb I have to take people to bomb full
body searches may be necessary find the
bomb before it's too late
right okay all right can do easy peasy
lemon squeeze me can I
nope okay all right may I know all right
um excuse me may I all right no ice
cream man do you uh okay no one here how
about in the ice cream no okay no bomb
how about your grunts nope okay all
right you are you hiding the bomb in
your pants okay nope whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa aah whoa [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] Hey whoa what the [ __ ] oh my
god oh my god oh my god the bomb is
gonna bomb on her like his ass or
something do you have a bomb anywhere
okay you sir you ever you got a bomb
anywhere ice-cream man do you have a
bomb no okay um no okay all right um no
one has a bomb Oh
in your hat oh I forgot about the hats
okay I get it some hats also the hats
okay - under there okay all right go do
the Hat how about your touchies okay all
right how about no okay no how about you
hat no daddy pants okay I've looked oh
hello oh that's a problem
ohyeah okay ah let's get that out of
here oh let's that's probably good
enough can you excuse me can you listen
boy I didn't I don't think I threw the
bomb far oh boy run run run run oh
[Music]
alright we're gonna consider that a
useful maiming you are fine sir and that
is fine all right ready
okay hey I did it where am I am I even
oh hey how's it going I did it yay I
feel good about myself and that yeah
Diane did you see Diane did you see I
sure saw Diana I saw okay all right
tough as nails avoids fancy cocktails
prevent death by ultra lasered I'll try
Oh jaymund has been captured into her
policy covers rescue from super villains
find a way to prevent her gruesome death
by the ultra laser okay all right I see
a little sortie worhty over here I'm
sorry sorry about that one um how about
we take of this bad boy and redirect oh
that oh uh excuse me
uh oh I'm sorry that's gruesome and
bloody sorry um let's see iris scanner
who's got the head look can you okay I
need this thank you can you put weight
no come back here come back here no no
no no come back here now look hey it
worked oh I need that thank you this
makes me feel powerful and strong also I
have no idea what direction I'm face
uh no God no no definitely not the
lasers which I doubt that going it's
super fun this game is like legitimately
incredibly fun I like this a lot
oh holy hell oh holy hell yeah say these
guys were 84 years old
no domes birthday celebration is about
to be ruined by a madman in a car both
he and his wife are policy holders and
must survive but that filthy clown is
your call well I'm gonna go ahead and
try to save the clown oh yes I don't
know why I'm gonna try to save the con
look out look out look out oh that's not
that's not good oh oh god oh oh oh God
oh okay all right what about what that
didn't go as well as I'd hoped
okay um get know that your clothes okay
that's your head okay this is your pants
you're naked now you don't need those
glasses clown man there's your clothes
okay there's just that let me take those
ridiculous shoes um stop
ow um all right I don't know how to okay
this one seems tricky this one's a
little tricky this one's tricky okay all
right tricky but we can do this we can
do this we can do this I'll take that
thank you very much okay that didn't do
anything
dole mmm
see ya bye huh this one's our pickle all
right I don't know how to do this one
yet so I'm going to move on to something
else because I don't want to be fiddling
with that forever there's something that
I'm missing there's something
fundamental that I'm missing there
there's but uh I'll get back to it that
was this Indiana Jane Raider of tooms
general badass the fanatics it with
don't want their Idol get Jane to the
chopper all right I'll do that I don't
know I don't know how that could be
possibly difficult it's gotta be easy
right that's cool Indiana Jane to the
inbound chopper the fanatics want their
Idol back and we'll bring everything
they have oh oh okay are you gonna tell
me how to get rid of a vehicle because I
don't know if I understand Jane look out
oh no okay that guy's done have your
glasses your helmet your outfit your
knife um no I said I said no all right
oh that guy's popping out of the
woodwork let's go with a bagel oh sorry
you're naked
no riding them
all right RPG man oh [ __ ] uh wait no I
meant to oh god damn it
alright let's try this again I believe
in you Jane you ain't gonna die Jane
something's happening in that Bush okay
here comes in coming Jane shine oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
ah got you baby you're gonna go that way
oh [ __ ] oh who did that whoa whoa nope
not today you know let's just take you
out of the equation here you don't know
if you don't have any pants what could
you possibly do it's gonna stand there
like an idiot oh sorry your grenade um
oops my bad
get him oh not quite but the other guy
yes yeah oh [ __ ] sorry about that Jane
don't [ __ ] up that jump if you [ __ ] up
that jump after everything I did for you
oh yeah oh yeah oh that's a badass
alright that is a badass look at that
badass Oh with plenty - okay that was
weird but we're gonna pretend like that
was normal Wow [ __ ] all you guys [ __ ]
yeah whoa okay so what I gotta do is I
gotta find some explosives to blow up
that goddamn other thing otherwise I'm
not gonna be able to do it right all
right let's try it I don't know how else
to get it done excuse me do you have a
bomb
you're awfully dirty but no bomb that I
can see
what do I do what I do
honestly I have no idea what to do with
this one would you like a nice massage
that's all I can offer at this point the
balloons I've tried to do that before
but it didn't work
Oh bye okay I guess he's dead anyway
okay that doesn't make the most sense
but okay sorry buddy happen sorry buddy
had to happen it looks like the clown's
gonna survive too so good job bye Larry
Oh dawn sorry dawn okay alright then
after you you'd think that after 84
years of life you wouldn't make that
many enemies but apparently you did
Diana become an excellent employee and
help prevent many of our clients oh yeah
you have also caused a lot of collateral
damage but they busts so far have been
acceptable okay alright you don't need
to mention my mistakes this section of
the building contains our most advanced
assignments your personal access code is
on 3 to 8 on your promotion to senior
loss prevention specialist we look for
seeing how you cope with an even higher
caseload than before I'm sure I'm gonna
do fine here these are the last ones oh
it's fun alright Billy Bob loves to hunt
big game our client is lost in the woods
and will not survive until morning help
him find his way back to camp I don't
know how I'm gonna do that but I'm gonna
give it my damnedest Billy Bob is lost
in the woods and will not survive until
morning okay find him and help him
return to camp
I don't wait I gotta find him what's
with the Harry Potter music Billy Bob
Billy Bob oh really Bob Billy Bob where
are you Billy Bob Oh Billy Bob there you
are hey Billy Bob hey
got your clothes you're gonna outdrive
the elements this way maybe I gotta like
get him a flashlight or something we got
to lead him back with flares and [ __ ]
Billy Bob Billy Bob oh hey Billy Bob Oh
Billy Billy Billy Billy Bob Billy Billy
Billy Billy [ __ ] idiot Billy all
right is there any bears or anything oh
[ __ ] oh oh oh [ __ ] oh oh Sh oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] there you go there's one we need
another one
well that bear sounded like it died a
horrible death oh wow okay all right
there's another one okay Billy oh boy
that's the problem okay hang on Billy
hang on Billy uh uh uh uh uh uh uh oh
there we go um oh [ __ ] I need one more I
need one more uh oh [ __ ]
how about burn it alive um yeah oh wait
oh we was over there oh okay oh hi Billy
Bob what are you doing over here now I
hope you're Billy Bob but you're not
Billy Bob that's gonna be a problem
all right let's hear this Billy Bob oh
oh that's a big bear Billy Billy why did
you bother the big bear all right those
bears are dead those bears are very dead
you're welcome buddy you did it I'm real
proud of you real proud of you oh yeah
hell yeah we did it yeah we're just
clogging our way through these things
all this God's awesome oh it's so cool
Adrian Kenneth develops high-tech
weapons beware of the automated laser
tank all right sure why not
that sounds good I don't know what he's
doing him whatever Barry's analyst II
holder Adrian awaits execution
so that he is safely extracted Adrienne
designed the automated laser tank now
guarding him
it is quite lethal there's a lot of whoa
okay that's it whoa what what are you
what why what how did you know I'm here
oh wait oh I see the solution you mind
if I have this sorry you don't need that
sure I'll [ __ ] yeah that's super cool
that's cool
Hey whoa why do you have two guns that
seems unfair sorry had to happen whoa
all right church uncles hey Adrian let's
go you don't need this boat I'll keep
this through myself
I guess we're good right Adrian is not
really worried about anything else so
Adrian should be fine
[Music]
easy peasy lemon squeeze me hello
everyone my name is markiplier I am in
the metrics it's all cool what the [ __ ]
I am NOT short I am very tall I am in
the metrics Blanc a blue ski
Kevin check this out hahahaha blue ski
it was me the whole time
run move that ass could you be any
slower I like to kick the air okay
alright Phenom Harley
I am very oh that's a problem I don't
know but I'll you will have seen the
solution of sow I fix that problem
probably well moving on all right what
do we got here
hello clown Bob failed clown terrible
juggler it seems you need to go over
some paperwork but Bob policy violation
what does that even mean Oh is he trying
to jump off a bill I'll mend clown Bob
to review his policy unfortunately the
situation is somewhat pressing ok Bob
Bob Bob Bob Bob wait Bob Bob you need it
Bob Bob wait but Bob you need to look at
your policy Bob you're oh there he goes
oh thank you Bob Bob wait bump
thank you Bob thank you have a good day
Bob we breathe we breathe okay well oh
ah and the hair flew whatever I probably
needed to go follow him down there's a
dark but hilarious one Bob Bob Bob Bob
here Bob you need to review your
policies thank you Bob I'll be right
down
Bob hang on wait Bob well done Bob Bob
did you uh did he sign it properly did
you sign it in triplicate oh I've got it
okay clone Bob got it alright thank you
Bob thank you Bob thank you this isn't
gun knife why is there a knife here like
oh manufacturing is experiencing an
incident at their Factory
what do you think about that all right
never mind then all right well I don't
know what I'm gonna do about Blake oh
the knife factory is going out of
control defend our clients against their
perfectly sharp knives is the Machine
the client or is the company the client
are the people in the comedy the client
I'm not on two percent sure how this is
gonna go
nice knives do I do something about this
oh I see with se Oh miss okay I think I
know what I need to do ah nope that's
not right
oh [ __ ] oh no oh my god okay so I was
wasting time all right can I come here
you
let's go you you get out of here okay
that's one down
what's wrong with yours anything oh
that's oh I don't like that sword dance
this is probably a problem so get those
out of there out of there whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
all right well that's some can you just
oh [ __ ] nope not today not today oh boy
oh oh whoa oh no no no no no no not bad
for me
about time damn it that other guy up
there did it took its sweet ass time
again over there all right
just two more come on three of six
clients aged mix save as many as you can
more of dr. pitas experiments of gone
berserk save at least three of the
town's folk sure I don't know why a
whole town has a policy with us but okay
I ain't gonna complain about it
mutant crows have ravaged the town oh
there's three clients to my pants okay I
got a bad over here is the bat useful oh
[ __ ] bird get batted oh [ __ ] all right
well that was one down where's the other
oh there's bad dude Birds over here
Fator [ __ ] come on birdie get out of
here they hit a bird with another bird
I said get out I got a frying pan drunk
all right that was easy enough and
hilarious boy hey okay this is a
hilarious weapon
hi look out boy no no no where to go
where to go where to go where to go
where to go oh no it broke no born bunk
bonk bonk bonk gimme gimme gimme gimme
oh he didn't die Punk come on Punk
oh he's dead okay whatever I didn't need
to save all of them totally fine totally
fine totally fine
hey you Birds oh sorry
and I stop please stop please stop all
right okay that's pretty good
I sure blocked him real hard we lost one
but I think it's okay all right guys
we're fine we don't need to worry about
anything that what is that a Gatling gun
why is there a Gatling gun floating in
the sky do I get Blanc's you move faster
or I Blanc you oh hi how long have you
been there come on come on come on
jiae's whoa hold up [ __ ] oh oh oh
suddenly nope sorry about that how about
Oh
excuse you Coby Wow oh wow wow wow no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no stop stop stop stop no no get
just go get away from my client good god
they don't stop him right at the end
there that'd be [ __ ] nope hey all
right I got it good god you're pieces of
[ __ ] I don't even know where I am
anymore am I facing the right way
absolutely not I'm facing the wrong way
okay one more huh one more will
easy-peasy
Kevin and Garcia lumberjack and a lover
of trees threat save the trees protest
is about to go very wrong this is gonna
do I don't know what's gonna happen but
I'm gonna see wait how did I face one
way again with the Lumberjacks
distracted trees are not the only ones
in danger ensure that Kevin and Garcia
survive hmm where's that guy's legs oh
there they are oh well that's a problem
um well who's gonna be into the scene
let's get a closer look at this
ah how the [ __ ] Hey okay let's not do
that let's not do that let's not do that
let's not do that
I think I know how to do this okay let's
turn you off off oh [ __ ] now even
bastard oh my god
trees are people too ah
sorry oh boy okay so that's Kevin
that's Kevin that's Garcia how do I save
you hey go get your go get it that's a
problem
um oh yeah
oh I see okay I think I know what to do
I think I know what to do okay I got
take this we're gonna yeah there we go
oh my god I'm amazing
alright come at me bro ah Oh wrong
segment wrong segment sharks are sorry
so sorry oh god he has no head that was
my bad
that was my bad I went about that very
wrong I'm gonna try that again here we
go
[Music]
easy peasy not too troublesome hey hell
yeah I think I did them all I think I
did all the games I think I did all the
missiles oh hey how's garbage to
complete to all our outstanding
assignments in a social work day it
appears we hired you just in time before
you go home for the day perhaps you
might enjoy our hastily put together
credits level oh I would love to bonus
levels and achievement and violence
against the graders if you change your
mind you can access the credits at any
time in the lobby well I was gonna I was
gonna do it you don't need to be snarky
about it I was already gonna do it so
you don't even need to you don't even
need to do anything about that I am
sorry you chose to come view the credits
yes I miss you they are short Oh
suffer through them I will unlock these
vaults next door okay
incorporated was developed by self
directed to try and make large amounts
of cash I cannot verify the accuracy of
this claim but what other motivation
could there be I mean make sense make a
cool game make a lot of money Oh these
two gentlemen made the questionable
choice to quit their jobs and create
this game feel free to be raped them on
Twitter if you hate it I will also leave
these deadly implements here for no
reason whatsoever fine people also
helped in various ways with the
completion of the game do you know dude
cuts and general laziness we were unable
to make each of them a character Oh No
as promised I will now permanently
unlock these vaults so you may enjoy the
bonus content oh maybe it's some point
else I gotta punish you all right
mr. Ryan drag I think your name was you
didn't need your eyes visit oh yeah
sorry sorry Oh pan wait no that's even
better pan hey buddy
oh no where'd you go okay that's not bad
I'm not gonna check out the bonus levels
but this game was awesome I love it I
really loved it and and honestly I just
got the vibe through like so it feels a
lot better I don't know what this was
like on vibe but the vibe Pro actually
does make VR a lot better than it has
been in the past it's more comfortable
to wear and it's just generally
all-around better like if you want to
try the vibe bro it's expensive though
so until the price drops I can't
recommend it but it's still pretty cool
so thank you everybody so much for
watching sorry about my mic dropping out
there I don't know when it did I only
know in the editing but I'll fix it for
you don't worry about that so thank you
everybody so much let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
if you want to see more cool VR games
like this in the future let me know down
there as well
thank you everybody again and as always
see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]